well despite 2020 being a trying year it
really hasn't stopped americans from
helping each other
throughout the pandemic americans have
been donating to charitable causes
in record numbers kirsten joyce joins us
now in the studio with the details and
also the breakdown of which generation
is leading kirsten denise we caught up
with ceo of fundraising platform
kindness david simerot he tells us that
charitable donations across the country
have risen 25 percent during
2020 as the year was full of
opportunities for people to step up
and help make the world around them a
better place they saw a huge spike in
donations specifically march
april and may due to the fact that there
were a lot of non-profits helping first
responders and other organizations
because of covid
the black lives matter movement got
people donating to the cause and of
course the elections
now let's take a closer look at which
generation gave the most as a percentage
of the demographic millennials
gave moore 74 compared to 66 percent of
the gen
z 63 percent of gen xers and 54 percent
of baby boomers
simurad says he's seen a real shift in
generations when it comes to what
matters he says millennials
are committed to causes what we are
seeing with these new generations is
that
for them money just doesn't do it like
you know being rich
or being successful in terms of having a
lot of net worth
that actually is not the most important
thing and uh
we are seeing that millennials are
really involved i think there is going
to be
a new definition of being rich and i'm
really proud that
my i'm part of a generation that's
helping through that shift
cimarron started kindness with the
mission to help nonprofits raise money
and to reduce the amount of money needed
to raise those funds the company doesn't
take cuts from the donations
it relies solely on donors giving an
optional tip which he says 90 percent do
the findings also reveal the average
donation by people across
our state 446 dollars to charity last
year
and that more than half of all americans
plan to donate more this year
denise